[Music]
what do you foresee as developments in
the
crypto or blockchain space or what are
you watching closely
well i think it's
it's funny because people get so caught
up in these kind of bowl and bear
markets and watching these coins and
saying like oh it's crazy it's down 20
it's up 20
and i think if you
i try not to get caught up in the weeds
there and just zoom out even further
because i think once you do that the
lines start to smooth out a bit and you
understand that
we're in the very early kind of first
innings of this entire rewriting of the
financial stack
and so you know that's part of the
reason why i created the podcast to
cover these things is because there's
just so much going on right now yeah we
need to bring the average consumer up to
speed so they know
how to get into this stuff early before
it's uh you know on paypal.com which is
what bitcoin and ethereum are now you
know
at modern underscore phi
oh that's why do you mean twitter yeah
just modern modern dot financing modern
finance modern dot finance modern
finance podcast check it out folks
on the tweets on the twitters it's at
modern underscore
phi
all right so you're tracking that you're
saying people get caught up in the micro
cycles that's right and they think it's
over so the fair weather speculators are
going to get their faces ripped off in
panic and then end up in a bad position
it's because they're always buying at
the highs and selling at the lows you
know i mean that's a very common thing
here and and i mean tim you know this
man you bought in right when everything
crashed or just before it crashed
and you got decimated for about 43 years
yeah i did i did yes i did i i
came in in probably what was it mid-2017
something like that
and promptly got my face ripped off
right but you were smart you didn't do
anything you just sat there it's just
like there there isn't a compelling
based on the thesis that i had
i mean which is a fancy way of saying
what i hoped would happen in the future
based on a couple of assumptions
there was no real reason to sell right
it was uh there are these really jagged
acute short-term
moves
but if i actually had high conviction
and the assumptions that led me to buy
in the first place it would be
hypocritical and self-defeating to sell
at that point so i didn't sell yeah yeah
and that was great because that ended up
it's probably what up at least five x or
more since since all that happened it's
up a bit it's up a bit yeah i mean it's
not up as much as it was
i guess end of april beginning may but
that's okay that's okay i mean i think
they're just these sort of hype and
deflation
cycles that you see in everything yeah
right and and and my biggest regrets in
all of investing
are actually the times that i sold
prematurely it's not having invested in
things
it is in
in other words it's not it's not having
missed opportunities to invest it's
having not
uh held the things i invested in for a
longer period of time shopify
sorry shopify shopify was a huge one i
mean that was my biggest misfire of all
time was but at the time that
represented in absolute dollars a really
significant win for me yeah to try to
get to the point where i didn't have to
be preoccupied
with money so it made sense right look
the logic of selling that actually made
sense
do i regret it yes
a better example would be in 2008
when i had
one
stock that i put a bunch of my like a
very double-digit percentage of my net
worth into can you guess what it was and
i put it in maybe in 2005.
uh wordpress
no
no although i am an advisor to wordpress
or rather to automatic and i'm a big fan
i think of what you would have bought
back then maybe amazon
yeah i bought amazon in like
2005 or something like that
uh maybe a little bit later taking a
look right now so wait you regret that
no you don't regret that obviously
that's something i regret selling oh you
sold it like so three years later i sold
it when
the
subprime crisis landed and everything
was just going through the floor
and
boy oh boy that was a mistake should
have held on to it and i didn't have
clear rules for myself then right it was
i i had rules for buying but not rules
for holding or selling and i think
people at least i get my i've gotten
myself into a lot of trouble
by having rules for buying which i i
sort of intuitively have a pretty good
feeling for i think you have an even
better feeling for it honestly you're
just that's absolutely one of your
mutant powers but then
how long to hold when to sell having
rules for that in advance is something
that i have historically not been
as good at
and
that has been a big problem uh certainly
with amazon is as sort of the textbook
example of that you know selling 2008 on
a panic and now it's
who knows 5 or 10x i have no idea yeah
oops
but yes all right so coming back to
blockchain or crypto i mean there's sort
of like one the latter is contained
within the former
what else are you paying close attention
to so uh of course you're observing the
sort of mass behavior right and this
behavior what else are you watching yeah
i mean we do a lot of crypto investing
at trueventures where i'm a partner
yeah so we've probably
deployed at say 50 million or so so far
this year in just in crypto related
deals so that's a a pretty decent chunk
of our fund
so it's something that we track very
closely and i would say that the problem
for the average consumer is that there's
just a lot of garbage in there there's
just a lot of crap so
you know i would say that unless you're
educated and you are
really deep in the space and you're
listening to all the podcasts and you're
you know reading all the different coin
desks every morning and
if you're at that level then you can
probably go out there and say if you
feel like it you can go out and say i i
believe i see where the momentum is
taking things
and so that's kind of what i do as a
profession now i don't recommend that
people do that
you know with their everyday just random
pick of a doggy coin because like all
the
you know there's a lot of there's a lot
of hype around these different you know
meme coins that are appearing
and
those come down crashing as fast as they
go up so we have a problem similar to
nfts where anyone can spin up a new coin
with just a few modifications to some of
the open source software that's out
there make a meme around it pump it and
then dump it and people get burned kev
coin yeah uh tim tim the k yeah we could
do
tim tim tokens
tokens and kev kev going i mean we could
like literally i within an hour we could
launch a new temptum uh token and and it
would be live and then we could put some
liquidity on uniswap we could get a
trading we get people i mean that
happens every single day yeah so i i
it's really frustrating
and you know it's
but it is what it is it's an unregulated
market there's a lot of stuff going on
it's super exciting there's a lot of
innovation happening a lot of really
high quality projects but a lot of of
craft to you knows buyer beware so you
just have to be careful on
on how you evaluate these different
opportunities and definitely do not buy
into the memes that are out there like
it's just that those are
those are silly and um
i'm not saying that one of them isn't
going to eventually because there's this
like fine line between community support
and that turns into something real
and a meme right and it's something
that's being used to kind of pump and
dump and so would you would you consider
dogecoin a meme coin it started off as a
meme coin and i think that
there are attributes of it that i before
they like em started tweeting about yeah
exactly elon elon started pumping up the
doge
well here's the deal with doge like even
the i i knew the founder really well uh
i had him on my podcast
seven years ago or whatever it was
and we talked about dogecoin and it was
a joke to initially it was just like a
fun like he set the supply super high
everybody was using it to tip using
these little bots on reddit and you know
i had literally millions and millions
and millions of dogecoin because they
were worthless
and i was tipping out you know ten
thousand at a time here five thousand
over here like it was just like we all
did it it was just fun right
and it was just kind of like a way like
a tip of the hat to someone like
monopoly money money monopoly money so
that has now
evolved into
it had a really strong community back
then it died down for a few years and
then the community came back and then
elon jumped on top of it
but it's still lacking a few things like
the underlying developers that are
working on it now this could be changing
and i've i've heard that they're
seriously considering refactoring the
code base but
it was just a dead project that had
minor bug fixes applied to it so there
was no real outside of it being a quote
unquote meme coin and being hilarious
and watching it go up in price
the
the technology stack that it was written
on wasn't being well it was being
maintained just so that it didn't break
there was no innovation happening there
and so that is not the future of
currency
like the the future like currency that
is going to to
to really be a real true utility has to
have an active development community
behind it supporting it and evolving it
over time
and so
that is happening on a handful of other
projects not so much on doge but there
is so much interest in doge now and it
is being listed on a bunch of of the
major exchanges again
i could see it wouldn't be crazy
uh if you said hey kevin guess what five
years from now
they now have you know 5000 active
developers doing all these really funky
weird things on doge i'd be like well
that makes sense because it had had the
community drive a lot of that you know
but but they're the outside of doge
they're they call me like the doggy
coins there are a bunch of other
doggy style coins that are just like
basically
well i'm sorry tim like
they're just they're
similar doggy coins i'm sorry that your
mind went there
but they're there
they're doggy themed coins that are just
like literally just out there for to get
people excited the prices go up the
whales sell and you know it's it ends in
tears and then ends in tears yeah
you